you living in the UK is that correct yep
whereabouts
I live in Edinburgh and borough okay and
will they have the amazing Comedy
Festival that's right and you you've
lived you've lived in Ireland you've
lived in England yeah I'm an Irishman
but I live in Scotland with my Scottish
family okay well here's my question we
hear that all of Europe is looking at
our election our presidential bat and
just stunned stunned by what's going on
yeah you must be watching this letter a
people out there they're they're they're
they don't move from the television
screen their mouths are open they
haven't spoken in months yeah they want
it to be over they want it to be over
everybody wants to people want to vote
in Europe yeah yeah they want to get
involved and say yes and a lot of you
know I mean the whole the candidates are
you know the candidates and they it's
kind of cheap to make
Trump jokes yep I think that's why we've
never done one the solemn pact
it is way too cheap how's that holding
out on you yeah I've never taught I
don't even not even sure who he is and
we the front of our show is just we talk
about other current events you know what
I have found I've had a lot of people
tell me oh you must love the Trump is is
in this race because it must make it so
much fun for comedians and I say
actually it's kind of hard because it's
so comical sometimes in and of itself
it's hard to put a comical spin on it
you know what I mean
yeah there's not a whole lot you can do
after he's finished talking yeah
[Applause]
you know you have to look for the good
in everybody right so he like you I look
at you know Hillary Clinton I'm not a I
can't say I'm a huge admirer of fellow
retention as a an entity I think she but
you look for the good so she's she's
she's she's you know she's kind of
remote but also chilly
so she's energy-efficient and then and
then you look at him hmm
there's got to be something there's got
to be something and everybody yeah but
what is it with with him and then
because you listen he has nothing really
nothing to say and he says everything
twice so you you feel totally unburdened
at the end because he's just he actually
makes less of nothing and you look for
he smiles he's smart he's a human being
but if you look at the smile I puzzled
me this smile I was trying to work it
out what is it say cuz people have a
bigger meaning with the old expression
who they are and I worked it out after
it took weeks but then I worked her is
the exact smile somebody would have if
they just told you they shot in the
glove box of your car
[Applause]
it's not that you're right you're right
I'm in good shape I makes her look good
yeah yeah
you